at this Hospital in Santa Cruz doctors
say they've seen an alarming increase in
the number of cases of dengue fever so
far this year although most patients
survive the disease it can be deadly
especially for children
my son fell ill on Wednesday night and I
took him to my local hospital where I
saw many children arriving with their
parents with the same symptoms as my son
nearly 70 percent of Bolivia's cases of
dengue are in Santa Cruz doctors there
say they're struggling to keep up with
the number of new patients
when the patient is seriously ill
they're moved to the Intensive Care Unit
here in the hospital we have eight beds
and they're always full we don't have
space for new patients the other problem
we have is Staff shortages we have
nurses and doctors who are ill with
Dengue fever and there's nobody to cover
their shifts
Dengue Fever can cause intense pain in
muscles and Joints it's spread by the
bite of the 80s mosquito which thrives
in tropical Urban settings poor
sanitation a lack of adequate drainage
and changing weather patterns are being
blamed for a spike in infections
the health Ministry is helping with the
fight against Dengue last Sunday we
deployed 5 000 people and together we
eliminated around 58 tons of disposable
items which are a risk for public health
when it comes to Dengue
sanitation workers are battling to get
the outbreak under control before
hospitals in Santa Cruz are overwhelmed
Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera